this video is sponsored by ting start
paying only for the data you actually
use and get $25 off with the link in the
description life in Zimbabwe has never
been easy since its independence the
southern African country has seen
factional violence international
sanctions and rampant political
instability but in the mid-2000s it lost
something even more fundamental its
currency surviving meant waking up as
early as 2:00 in the morning trekking to
the nearest ATM and then waiting in line
on a good day you'd be able to withdraw
the equivalent of about one or two US
Dollars the maximum allowed by the
government or you might find after
losing sleep and waiting for hours that
no more money was left
that's because around 2007 Zimbabwe
experienced the second highest inflation
in history after post-war Hungary it's
hard to know exactly how bad it got as
the government stopped reporting numbers
after 100,000 percent inflation when a
loaf of bread cost 30 billion Zimbabwean
dollars employees stopped going to work
when their annual salary wouldn't even
pay for their bus ride home and vending
machines were put out of service unable
to hold the billions of coins that a
single can of soda would cost to keep up
the central bank kept printing bigger
and bigger banknotes a million dollars
one hundred billion and finally 100
trillion worth a whole 40 US cents so
how did sim Bob way get here and how did
this devastating economic crisis help
launch Africa's financial technology
revolution
Zimbabwe is home to the largest
waterfall in the world Victoria Falls
over twice the height of Niagara and
whose tumbling water can be heard 40
kilometres or 25 miles away further
south are the intricate stone ruins of
an 11th century Palace City and savannas
everywhere in between
hold Africa's big five lions leopards
elephants buffalo and rhinos
unfortunately few will ever get to see
these wonders because in addition to
being blessed with natural beauty
Zimbabwe is also cursed with an
abundance of gold platinum coal and
diamonds all things which led Cecil
Rhodes of the British South Africa
company to invade the land with a newly
invented maxim gun at the end of the
19th century the company run territory
was almost entirely governed and
exploited by the tiny white minority
years later two rival factions emerged
Zimbabwe African peoples Union supported
by the Soviet Union and the National
Union backed by Mao's China in 1980
Zimbabwe gained its independence and the
National Party won its first election
almost immediately with the spirit of
nationalism strong leader Robert Mugabe
began doing what all good dictators do
consolidate power his army trained by
North Korea under Kim il-sung began
murdering dissidents he granted himself
the power to dissolve Parliament's
declare martial law and removed all term
limits Mugabe Zathura terian rule lasted
37 years just four short of Africa's
record and teamed with corruption he
once accidentally let slip that his
opponent had won 73% of the vote in the
last election before quickly correcting
himself this insatiable thirst for power
had more than political consequences in
2000 his government began forcibly
seizing land from white farmers for
redistribution officially the goal was
to correct for the country's unjust
colonial past
in reality the policy helped him by
political support the effects were
devastating the new farmers usually had
little or no experience and sometimes no
interest in agriculture from 2000 to
2009 total agricultural output was cut
in half
with some farms producing only 1/10 as
much as before by wiping out its two
largest crops corn and tobacco land
reform both single-handedly destroyed
its economy and decimated its food
supply meanwhile many of its skilled
farmers fled for safety as farms became
less productive and demand for the
little food left rose
so did prices and fast daily inflation
reached 98% and Zimbabwe's economy
totally collapsed shops if they were
still open increased prices multiple
times a day as 12 million people
struggled to find food water and power
now to slow inflation a government must
do two things first it has to stop
printing money basic economics says
increasing money and circulation
simply decreases its value second and
much harder is a government has to
convince its people that his currency
has value Mugabe did neither to fund its
involvement in a second Congo war the
Reserve Bank kept printing new higher
denominations but it just couldn't keep
up the banks spent five hundred thousand
US dollars a week ordering new banknotes
which by the time they arrived from
Germany were already worthless twice it
rida nominated removing ten zeros from
all banknotes in 2008 and twelve in 2009
but to no avail
Zimbabwe ins didn't believe their
currency had value and therefore it
didn't in other words prices kept rising
largely because people expected them to
and soon no more money was left there
just weren't enough bills to go around
and that's when Zimbabwe got creative
like much of Africa the vast majority of
its population is unbanked in advanced
economies about 92 percent of people
have some kind of bank account but that
number is only 20 percent in sub-saharan
Africa here where the number of
transactions is high but balances are
low branch locations and ATMs just
aren't very profitable leaving Zimbabwe
with 6.5 ATMs per 100,000 people Uganda
with 4.2 and Niger with 1.7 compared to
the United States
174 or Macau's 324 Zimbabwe ins lacked
the infrastructure necessary to keep
money safe or transfer it between people
not only does this hide the flow of
money granting cover to criminals and
making it impossible for the government
to regulate or tax it but it's also
physically dangerous many who live in
cities regularly send money to family
members in the country requiring they
take a one or two day journey themselves
or hire someone to do it for them and
risk having it stolen but while this
lack of banks would ordinarily only slow
the continents technological progress
African entrepreneurs turned it into an
advantage what it does have a lot of our
phones in many of its country's total
mobile phone penetration stands at 80
percent these two things allowed
countries like Zimbabwe to leapfrog over
checks and credit cards and then surpass
more advanced economies in mobile
payments in places like the u.s. the
ubiquity of banks and credit cards
actually holds back new technologies
tapping or texting would make sending
money much easier but first you and I
need the same app hence why there are so
many competitors chase pay google pay
square Wallet PayPal Apple cash cash app
Zell and venmo the hard part isn't
building the app it's hitting a critical
mass of users in Africa the selling
point was obvious either take a two-day
bus ride or send a text and because many
of its countries are dominated by
telecom monopolies that company can
ensure quick and universal adoption in
2007 for example Kenya's largest mobile
network operator Safaricom launched
m-pesa M for mobile and paisa meaning
money each MP a user is associated with
a SIM card allowing them to text anyone
else money there's no charge to signup
or deposits and fees are minimal but
what's truly revolutionary is that it
doesn't require a bank account to
deposit or withdraw you simply find an
agent over 100,000 middlemen who get
paid to collect and then bring cash to
or take out cash for when users withdraw
or transfer money it's so convenient
that it's used for almost everything
school fees water electricity food and
so on in Zimbabwe the preferred app is
called eco cash which in 2007 had 6.7
million users compared to its two
million bank accounts that year the
Reserve Bank reported digital payments
accounted for 90% of its ninety seven
point five billion dollars in total
transactions making its economy
virtually cashless even digital currency
however isn't immune to political
incompetence as a landlocked country
Zimbabwe relies on its powerful rivers
for water and electricity the Kariba Dam
alone provides over half of the nation's
electricity making its frequent droughts
extremely dangerous
in July echo net generators fail to
start after a power outage disabling its
mobile payment platform and therefore
effectively the national economy lifting
a nation out of poverty is so difficult
not for lack of resources but rather
because solutions require deep political
changes to rebuild its economy Zimbabwe
must first manage its inflation to
manage inflation it has to build
confidence and to do that its government
requires reform that hope came in 2007
when Mugabe was deposed after nearly
four decades of economic ruin but fear
promptly returned when this year
Zimbabwe reintroduced its dollar an
inflation again began increasing yet
even while countries like Zimbabwe
clearly still have plenty of unresolved
challenges those very same problems are
sometimes the necessary ingredients for
innovation mobile money is at best a
convenience for most of us but for the
world without bank account's it's life
changing by making transactions faster
and more secure apps like m-pesa
literally increase the value of money
theft is reduced there's less waiting in
line or time spent delivering money
credit is more accessible to
entrepreneurs
it increases savings and improves
accountability Africa is the world
leader in Mobile Money precisely and
only because it previously had so
are to come as the youngest continent
and on the receiving end of massive
amounts of loans its financial
revolution is just the beginning what's
genius about m-pesa is how it
piggybacked on existing technology
phones were widespread and SIM cards and
carriers were well established in Africa
likewise the expensive part of cell
service towers and equipment has already
been built by big companies like
t-mobile and Sprint Tim can help you
save money by using those exact same
networks in the US but without a monthly
plan the truth is Wi-Fi is everywhere we
spend most of our day at home school
work and shopping so it might not make
sense to pay for the same two or five or
10 gigabytes a month with ting you only
pay for exactly what you use so it's a
good way to save money the average bill
is $23 a month and if you use my link in
the description you get a $25 credit
which is essentially a whole month free
thanks to ting for sponsoring this video
and to you for watching
you